let's say someone is going on a road
trip they've decided la is the place
they want to live they say hey can we
meet for coffee and can you give me some
do's and don'ts and how do I make routes
here how do I land work I think that for
someone moving here the advice I would
give them and give them two pieces of
advice the first one would be don't
break the bank with where you choose to
live your day-to-day life make sure that
you're living within your means and that
your savings which hopefully you're
moving here with you can extend as long
as possible all the considerations about
where you think you might be working
where you think you might be hanging out
if you don't know LA yet then you're not
gonna be able to make that decision so
find someplace that you can live and
then once you know the city after a few
years and you are sure that you want to
stay you sure that you want to keep
doing this
then you can find that neighborhood you
go that's where I want to be and you can
go there at that point that'd be the
first piece of advice the second piece
of advice would be really to take stock
in your own network who you can meet or
who you know that can help you meet
someone but also take stock in yourself
and where your strengths are and where
your weaknesses are as a person as a
professional and really think about how
you are going to first navigate the
industry because everyone's method of
navigation is gonna be really different
so the more you can reflect on yourself
and think about how you can fit in the
more success I think you'll have when
you try to do that do you go to a lot of
meetups I go to a fair amount of meetups
I guess I co-host sort of a monthly one
with a friend and doing just we just
meet up and we just basically pick a
place and time and say if you're a
writer or you're interested in writing
if you're not really anyone is welcome
we're writers we want to hang out if
that sounds fun to you you can
attend to you don't have to be a writer
you can just show up and the first one
got way bigger than we thought it would
be and so as we continue to host them we
have to make sure that we're places that
have this space for it because there's
something I think really frein about
writers meeting up to hang out with
other writers because I'm not
necessarily gonna get a job directly
from you maybe partially through you
because you know someone or something
like that but no one feels like they're
there to sell or be sold to someone so
we can just kind of meet up and talk
shop together and commiserate about just
this common situation that we all find
ourselves in you think it's also
interesting because so many writers well
and now I'm generalizing here that
they're introverted or they're just more
they're solitary creatures just because
of the nature of what they do okay so to
meet other people like that in a city
that's so sort of extroverted it's kind
of refreshing yeah I think that's also
been a big part of it and what I always
tell people at these meetups is just
never worry about talking about yourself
just approach someone and don't ask them
about them ask them about their project
ask a writer about their project and
they'll just start talking to you
because that's the thing that they love
and so you can really get people to open
up by just saying hey what are you what
are you working on right now or I saw
that thing that you wrote tell me more
about that and I think a lot of the
introverted writers are particularly us
feature writers who tend to live a more
isolated lifestyle are willing to open
up a lot more when you're like okay I
don't have talked about me I've talked
about my story cool right and there's no
like qualifiers we're not like judging
like oh well what categories this person
fit in it just tell me about your
project I like that that's like a safe
question yeah
well it's also it's funny because
everyone prepares their pitches for when
that executive they get in the elevator
with them and oh you're a writer what's
your project and everyone gets on theirs
but as soon as another writer says tell
me about your project and you know that
well they're not
gonna buy your project they can't buy
your product cuz there's another writer
and everyone's pitches get way better
when they're talking to someone where
there's no pressure and so you say talk
about your project I think oh well it's
a story about this and they get really
animated and they get the best pitch of
their lives because it's relaxed and
they're just talking to someone else
who's just like them that's really cool
so it's just like dinner and drinks and
everybody hangs out and just talks about
their projects and being a writer yeah I
mean usually we we try to go somewhere
that has like snacks available but it's
mostly just like drinks and it's just
sort of like mingling and cocktails and
just hanging out cool and then on
Twitter it looks like you've built a
strong community there yeah and that's
where I usually get the word out about
whatever sort of meetups or mixers I'm
trying to put together I should really
give credit to my friend for putting
most of it together and he just kind of
tags me and we end up co-hosting which
really means just we're just there as
well because we're the ones that told
everyone to go meet up at this place at
this time was that something you did
back home or is this sort of the new
David coming here no that was not
something I did back home I think if I
was left to my own devices I would
probably stay in and read a book and I
should give credit to my girlfriend for
pushing me in the past year to be more
vocal in my opinions about screenwriting
and the craft and also just pay
attention to the networking side of the
career that I've chosen and it is part
of the job and it doesn't have to be a
bad part of the job but if you're not
naturally inclined to do it it does take
I think that little push for someone to
remind you you should also be doing this
part of the job great
and speaking of opinions on
screenwriting have you worked as a paid
script reader I have not worked as a
paid script reader for a company I've
interned at to to places where I was a
reader and I would write coverage but I
do
private work for clients for reading
work and I gave notes and calls and line
edits as well this is something that's
new that you've done yeah this is a new
endeavor for me I have been giving notes
to friends and doing that for a long
time and a lot of them were really
responsive with the quality of the notes
that they felt I was given and a lot of
them were encouraging me to they say you
should do something you're actually
really good at cubing notes and figuring
out not what you would do but what I
should do for my story and figuring out
where it might be not holding together
as well and providing solutions while
still allowing me the freedom to write
my own story I just get a lot of good
response for the notes I was giving and
so with some encouragement
I just recently a few months ago started
taking on private clients mostly which I
find through Twitter believe it or not
and your website has the way to contact
you if people want to submit their
scripts yeah I have a whole page that
lists all my script services and then I
just have an email people reach out to
me for the availability and rates and if
we can do it I'm up to read anything
you